hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from the 1959
candidates tournament now here we have
Paul Harris with the white pieces
playing against the Bobby Fischer and
it's interesting to note that prior to
1959 candidates tournament Bobby Fischer
and Paul Karras met once over the board
already it was also in 1959 in the very
strong tournament and Fischer actually
won their first encounter so bowing into
this game Bobby Fischer actually has a
positive result against Paul Karras
before the 1959 candidates so it's hard
to say how impacted the psychologically
Karras was by this but I don't really
think he was but then again he might
have been so let's see this game and
Fischer didn't really win a lot of games
in the 1959 candidates but those he won
were incredibly exciting so let's check
it out
Harris has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 and we've already seen a photo
of Harrison Fisher playing in the 1959
candidates tournament I'm sure you
remember pal Benko enjoying the view
above the board as there are no other
photos I did find one but that was that
one was like really really poor quality
so I decided to use this one again so
for those of you who are maybe new to
this tournament and this channel you can
enjoy this great piece of history so
that being said let's let's see this
game Fischer goes Knight to f6
we have Knight to f3 and g6 now so the
Indian game we have Bishop to f4 and
Fischer goes for the London system
Bishop to g7 Knight B to d2 and c5 we
have C 3 C captures on d4 C captors on
d4 and d5 immediately this is only move
6 and with this d5 move Fischer actually
decides to sacrifice a pawn and the
Charis accepts it he plays Bishop
capture some b8 rook captures and Queen
to f4 check simply checking the King and
going for the a7 point now if you block
with the Queen then Queen captures on a7
will immediately attack the rook so
Fisher decides to play Bishop to d7
blocking check attacking the Queen and
caris grabs the pawn Queen captures on
a7
we have Knight to e4
and now III tonight's 2d to capturing
the night we have night captures and now
II five so Fisher immediately wants to
open up the center he doesn't wanna wait
to give carries the opportunity to
Castle he doesn't wanna allow Bush of d3
and castles
so Knight to b3 first we have castles by
Fisher and now Queen to c5 the problem
would a move like Bishop to d3 preparing
castles is that after each captures on
d4 you either have to play each captures
on d4 and allow the opening of the
center or if you play Knight captures on
d4 then you get Queen to c7 and again
you can't castle so this would be very
unfortunate because if you castle now
then rook to e8 rook to e8 and your
queen is trapped there is nowhere to
hide
so after this castles by Fischer caris
goes for Queen to c5 he wants to get his
Queen out of the way as soon as possible
roof to c8 harassing that Queen and
putting a rock on the open sea file
Queen to b4 and now rook to e8 again
threatening to open up the center would
eat captures on d4 and here Karis can't
afford to wait any more
he plays Bishop to e2 and he allows
Fischer to capture on d4 so it captures
on d4 and here you can either castle and
maybe allow the captures on e3 but you
know that's not really going into white
favor so Karis decides to play Knight
captures on d4 and here we have Queen to
h4 again Fischer doesn't allow carries
the castle if Karis castles now then
simply Bishop captures on d4 and black
wins the game Queen captures Queen
captures if you captured upon row
capture sunny - you lose the piece and
it's a winning game for black so after
this Queen to h4 move Karis decides to
play Queen captures on b7
attacking the bishop on d7 but now
Fischer plays Bishop captures on d4 and
now you have so many options to choose
from
what do you do one thing you have to
immediately see that if you decide to
castle with the idea okay I'm down a
piece at the moment but
we're gonna grab the bishop here or the
bishop on b7 but that doesn't really
work because Bishop to c6 moves this
Bishop out of harm's way also attacks
the Queen and after Queen moves you will
simply move this bishop for example to
e5 and you're still up a piece
threatening checkmate all is well for
black another idea after this Bishop to
d4 move if you play it captures on d4
then you immediately lose the game due
to rook captures on e2 with check King
captures and now rook the c2 check King
moves Queen captures on f2 and now it's
all over
you can't stop both Queen e2 check and
Queen d2 check checkmate
if you try some checks for example quita
b8 check to try some Queen e5 check
ideas simply push up to c8
there are no more checks and it's game
over so after this Bishop characters on
d4 by Fischer that cares plays the only
move that is actually but for White
Queen characters on d7 and now we have
Bishop captures on b2 still Fischer
doesn't allow cares to Castle you have
to do something about that rook
so rook to d1 and now we have Bishop the
c3 check and there is no more castling
for Karis King to f1 and here there is
only one move that allows black to
continue his onslaught and that is d4
again threatening to open up the center
and the problem would a move like Queen
to g4 for example trying to exchange
Queens to stop Black's attack if you go
Queen g4 then simply Queen captures and
Bishop captures and while this is
attacking the rook and c8 now Fischer
has time to play D captures on e3 now
you can't grab the rook because of e to
check and the black wins the game so
first you have to grab the pawn and
after something like rook the c5 Icarus
would still be up upon but which this h1
rook out of the game and with the weak a
2 and B 3 pawn it's a better position
for black so Karis decides not to go for
this after this d4 move by Fischer he
plays he captures on d4 but now comes
Queen to e4 threatening Queen captures I
need to check which will be followed by
Queen to e1 sacrificing a queen for 4
meetin one so went to G for offering to
exchange Queens this is the strongest
move for White Queen to c2 and this is a
this is a deadly move you're you're
threatening to capture the pawn on a2
but there is an even greater threat for
example if Karis tried something like h4
they maybe try and get this rock into
the game via rope to h3 then you lose
immediately due to Queen captures rook
on d1 with check only move Bishop
captures and now rook to e1 this is
checkmate
so after this Queen to c2 g3 so now
Queen captures on d2 d1 doesn't work
King can always escape to g2 now comes
Queen captures on a2 and here Fischer
was really attacking Harris for the
entire game he was making him think I
don't really have the information about
the time on the clocks but I can imagine
Karis was in some serious time trouble
here and with a move like Bishop to f3
you can always fight your King to g2
White can continue playing this game but
instead of Bishop to f3 Karis played
Bishop to d5 a Bishop to b5 attacking
Fischer's rockin e8 and he thought ok
maybe after the rook moves that will
only then play King G to get my rook
into the game and all is well but
unfortunately Bishop to b5 loses the
game so it's a very nice position if you
want to pause it
find the move Fischer played that wins
the game I will give it a couple of
seconds as usual so you know feel free
to beat Karis in this position for those
of you who were able to find it
congratulations you're an excellent
player and for those of if you just want
to enjoy the show
before showing what Fischer played I
will first show one move that also seems
like a winning move but it's not so if
you found this one you will then get a
draw against Carris if you found Bishop
to e1 with the idea of Queen captures f2
checkmate then you only get a draw if
your idea was ok if he plays rook
captures honey
anyone then I will play rook captures
and if King captures rook to c1
checkmate yes this might be so but again
if you play Bishop to e1 then carries
can simply bring the bishop back Bishop
to e2 and there's no more attacking
ideas for white here for black the move
Fischer played after Bishop
b5 that actually once the game is Queen
to d5 attacking the bishop on b5 and
this undefended rook on h1 so you can
see the irony in this game
Karis tried so hard for the for the
entire game to get this rock into the
game and now that he finally played g3
enough to play King g2 and bring it into
the game
this allowed Fischer to actually use
this use this idea to win the game so
there's really nothing to play here if
you try something like there's really
nothing to try here you can either give
up the rook or the bishop if you give up
you're just down a piece so Karis tried
Bishop captures on e8 but now Queen
captures on h1 with check King it only
move now rook captures on e8 with check
King to d3 and here you can try a lot of
things for example if you play something
like Queen to d5 you can even give up
the bishop on c3 and we you will
eventually checkmate black but Fischer
played Bishop to e1 simply as the King
was attacking the bishop and c3 also the
rook was attacking the Queen on h1 the
Queen and g4 is defending the rook on d1
so Fischer simply played Bishop t1 now
the bishop is no longer attacked and in
this position Karis resigned the game
because there is no move white can
actually make here there's no way to
attack this Bishop twice as the Queen
can't attack it the King can't attack it
so there's really nothing to play here
whatever you play you're getting
checkmated whatever you play so Queen f1
check for example King moves now Quincy
4 check forcing the King to the B file
Ruby a check and now but rip to c3 or
Queen to a for both this checkmate so
not no point in doing anything like this
so after Bishop do you want
Paul carries to resign the game and it's
a pretty impressive victory for for the
sixteen-year-old Bobby Fischer this is
move 27 crushing Paul Karis like this
and for those of you who are maybe new
to this tournament on or this channel I
will show the final standings of this
tournament as you can see like I said
Bobby Fischer didn't really win a lot of
games he won't eight of them but all
eight wins were we're pretty impressive
unlike for example tal who won
in games that's twice as much but you
know he did win the tournament but
interesting fact is that like I said
Fischer won the first encounter with
Paul Kara's in the 1959 Series
tournament but in the candidates
tournament of 1959 Fischer had a draw
against Carris he won two games and Paul
Harris won two games and another
interesting thing is that both games
Fischer won in both games carries one
were worn by the black pieces so that's
a very interesting fact and I don't
really know what to make of it you know
how come they went all four games were
wins by by the black pieces so very
interesting and I do hope you enjoyed
that here we can we can enjoy this photo
of Karis playing against Fischer one
more time
so I do I do hope you enjoyed it and I
will consider doing some more games from
the candidates tournament of 1959 but
after that I will probably start doing
as you know whoever won this tournament
will face Mikhail Botvinnik for the
World Chess Championship match so I will
probably do couple of games from that
World Chess Championship match as it's
quite quite the match and you know also
filled with very interesting stories so
yeah thank you for watching as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
yeah like I said probably will show a
couple more games from the 1959
candidates tournament but after that you
know I'm also taking suggestions what's
the cover next as you know the Kent the
real candidates of 2018 are coming soon
so I do have to you know prepare for
that as well so thank you all and I will
see you soon